Хочете утеплити свою оселю?
Є кілька можливостей  зробити це,
заощадивши чимало грошей. Існують державні,
місцеві та іноземні кредити на підвищення енергоефективності житла.
Цей кредит надає держава з 2014 року
у межах Державної цільової програми енергоефективності.
Кошти можуть отримати власники приватних будинків,
житлово-будівельних кооперативів
та об'єднання співвласників багатоповерхових будинків.
Їх видають державні банки - "Ощадбанк", "Приватбанк",
"Укргазбанк" та "Укрексімбанк".
Повний перелік товарів, які можна купити за допомогою
"теплого кредиту", складається з понад 20 найменувань.
Серед них теплоізоляційні матеріали, твердопаливні котли,
економічні котли, сонячні панелі тощо.
Держава компенсує від 20 до 35% кредиту
для фізичних осіб і від 40  до 70 % для ОСББ
для ОСББ та житлових кооперативів.
ля отримання цього кредиту варто звенутись до банку-партнера.
Щоправда державні кошти, передбачені на кредитування цього року,
вже вичерпались. Взяти кредит можна буде з наступного року.
Існують понад триста обласних, районних та міських програм з енергоефективності,
які діють майже в усіх регіонах України,
Ці програми фінансуватимуть з місцевих бюджетів.
Вони найчастіше передбачають погашення частини щомісячної оплати відсотків
за кредитом на енергозбереження житла.
Розмір відшкодування, залежно від регіону,  -
від 5 до 20%.
Європейська программа енергоефективності в житловому секторі
IQ energy стартувала в Україні два роки тому.
Скористатися нею може будь-яка людина чи ОСББ,
які хочуть поліпшити енергоефективність житла.
Для цього слід вибрати товари чи обладнання у каталозі технологій,
який складається з майже 7.000 найменувань і доступний онлайн.
овар слід придбати, оформивши  кредит в одному з банків-партнерів,
а згодом подати заявку на компенсацію
35-40%.